myself I was like and I kind of giggled
and then I realized it wasn't alone
I don't think our sponsor Verity Verity
is a family brand founded by Alex his
wife Carrie his twin brother Mike that
channels their love of the beach
lifestyle into clothing for life's
greatest moment Verity crafts clothes
that feel as good as a day at the beach
and they are backed by their guarantee
of quality Verity is giving all dumb
people Town listeners an amazing deal 20
off your order head to ferritybrand.com
DPT and use code
dpt20 at checkout for 20 off your order
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population
is what I'm going to ask he is here the
great Tom pop who does a podcast at this
wonderful Network breaking bread with
Tom Papa
great loaves of bread from you sir you
make great bread you make great comedy
your phenomenal Radio Show on Netflix is
a joke on Sirius Radio amazing
everything you're doing is wonderful we
were in the back we were at The Green
Room at The Comedy Store one night
frazzled as we're rushing to get there
we see you there and we just have the
most lovely conversation your
mid-sentence you go walk out on stage
crush it you give us a lovely
introduction and we have a great set and
I'm like this is what it should be nice
right the only bad part of that story is
you guys having a good set too
the rest of it is really set the table
beautifully for us that's just dumb and
you know what else is dumb the world the
world is getting Dumber I don't know if
you've noticed it out in this universe
you do a lot of NPR stuff so yeah
this is sent in by uh Nicole Miller at
Nicole you Miller Nicole Miller comedy I
think she's a comedian yes Nicole Miller
very funny okay all right after high
school with the Nicole Miller hey now if
it's that Nicole Miller very funny uh I
think I have a Nicole Miller tie that's
a different person that's a Nicole
Miller though right right all right I
think that's Cole Haan
Tulsa woman says she's without a car
after Sam's Club gave it to a stranger
what let me get into it wait is there a
valet at Sam's Club I don't know do you
belong to any of the clubs of Costco
Costco Sam's Club I am Costco but I yeah
but I haven't been there since instacart
wow wow weird Flex from Tom yeah
I don't go out for my groceries well
this Tulsa woman went to a Sam's Club uh
she said that a Sam's Club employee
handed her car keys to someone he
thought was the owner who then took off
with the car this to me is my worry
about it it's not on the guy it's on the
[__] guy who drove away with the car
Costco's version of Walmart has valet
yes pretty impressive I mean yeah that's
boosh yeah bougie bougie and like can't
I bet you can get your car cleaned at
Sam's Club right detail this guy yeah
they have carts right you don't know the
parking it might be I have a a quick can
I can I jump a job I was seeing the
Grateful Dead in Hartford Connecticut
and in the 90s and uh a guy that we were
with was tripping on acid and didn't get
into the show and he was just wandering
the streets of Hartford and the ballet
came up and and just as he was stumbling
down the street pulled up opened the
door so here you go sir and he got in
the car started driving on it started
driving and the only thing in the car
and we found this out because at the end
of the night with the concert was over
he showed up at the hotel he's like God
gave me a car oh my gosh it was Alexis
the only thing in the car was a tape a
cassette tape there was no personal
identifying effects at all well there
was probably in the glove box we didn't
look in there yeah but it was just
Immaculate pop the tape in it was just a
Jesus tape about fulfillment in your
life
and I had to take him to the parking lot
I'm like and I went in the glove box and
I'm like God didn't give you a card this
is Kelly something brother
bulging out he's like I don't get the
Lexus no and you missed a killer show
they did a Scarlet fire and then wound
up doing a help slip Franklin's you're
an idiot oh that's wild so you first had
knowledge of this happening yeah it
can't happen but my friend was on acid
right I don't know why this guy just
drove away I'm not willing to bet that
the guy who the uh the valet guy was
probably on acid too the thing where you
walk up to the car you thought was yours
and open the door and that's happened at
some point
I was in Larchmont with uh with my mom
and my daughter and and Amy I think was
with me too we went like I don't know
just a daisy in my and my mom and I and
we just went into a store and we came
back out and we had parked across the
street and I was in my gray car my gray
bolt and I'm walking down the street and
I see the gray Bowl parked about where
we were we opened up the doors we got it
we sat down and there's like a water
bottle in the center thing that is not
yeah you know throw it away I don't know
this water bottle closest to having a
real life feeling of when you're in a
dream
same color everything same kind and we
sit down in the thing and we realize
like oh my God we just all got into a
car that violated someone's face
violated we got out and we're like yeah
wasn't that a bit we did with Carrie
Kenny silver when she was on the first
cheap seats where she was an erotic cake
maker and she just kept telling us like
so I went into the place and she gets in
her car and as she's trying to do her
like talk to the camera it's not
starting and then she ends at the end of
each thing is like this is
getting it gets out of it what a weird
feeling to be in other people's space it
was I felt so weirdly wrong and like
your friend probably you guys were all
honest
Amazon acid okay so this woman shared
her frustration on social media which
has had millions of views which I'm sure
she's very excited about Heather
simonini
fluffy flaky pasta she dropped off her
car at the Sam's Club on 71st and Mingo
on September 27th never forget where you
were on 9 27 27. for a tire change
[__] go to Jiffy Lube what are you
doing so this is that's why it's not
ballet it's their service yes like Sears
would happen like you go to the service
department
and she said she when she came back no
one could find her keys or her what year
Honda Civic what year what year Honda
Civic is she freaking out over like I
would be like 2004. 2008
2013 Honda Civic all right get your
answers in one of you is one year off oh
nice her 2014.
with how many thousand miles on it 2014.
still nine years it says a lot about
this woman eight and a half to nine
years
uh uh a hundred wait you said still with
how many miles that makes me want to go
48 000. 48 000 yeah
110 110. 18 000 miles
searching back to get Tire changes
all right well she needs a tire chart
2014 Honda Civic Heather Simone
who also is not your car you show up to
Sam's Club and you just drive off in
someone's car she recorded a video after
the incident shared it on social media
which has 2.5 million views on Tick Tock
whoa Shannon is your car back no but
look at how many hits I've got
it's impressive I call that a hit and
run man the man that received my car
keys just asked for them explain
simonini the man handed him the keys and
didn't ask for ID or membership but he
probably said I have the Honda Civic
they said are these your keys yeah those
are and he also maybe would have thought
the whole time those were his skis
you're saying yeah are you saying it's
maybe a situation like mine where he had
a 2014 Honda Civic because wood cars are
Civic and they go these keys he goes yes
and then of course once he gets in you
would hope he realizes this guy was
lurking
correctly looking for something he
probably came thinking he was gonna get
like a big thing of pretzels or
something
he recorded videos of one of the
managers talking to the police handsome
the keys manager said to the officer he
goes out and I have footage of him going
out to the side like all right whoever's
writing this article let's get to the
real Point come on we don't need to use
all the quotes the manager even told the
police in the video that what happened
to simonini should have never happened
yeah yeah
of course you say that what a powerful
stance yes
the courage to say that this should have
never happened that you guys shouldn't
have given her car to someone else no he
did okay for evaluation shouldn't have
happened thanks that's my that's my take
I go out on a limb here I don't want to
get feet any feathers here but that
should not have happened I'm gonna say
that we'd like to retract our original
statement where we said it should have
happened yes we are gonna go on record
and say a lot of people are saying it
should have happened I'm not saying that
but a lot of people are saying
uh the process is you check the ID to
make sure it matches the owner of the
car explain the manager the office our
associate handed him the key you can see
the officer's stun reaction in the video
Sam's Club gave on uh news six they gave
this statement we take the situation
very seriously we're doing everything we
can to make sure the member is taken
care of translation kicking it down the
road we've been in touch with the member
and provided a rental car for her that's
not enough you might have to go get her
a new car yeah I think you do we are
also cooperating with local law
enforcement don't they have insurance
for this they have got to have insurance
like valet insurance that this would
happen oh you would think yeah it'll hit
a certain Mark to where then it is more
cost effective for them what do you guys
think about air tags
and I have a uh it's like a home
collector car and somewhere in that car
is an air tag that's a smartphone I know
at all times exactly where that car is
damn I don't have any air tags but I've
been thinking like why not absolutely I
have a tile I have one in my personal
bag that I have all the time I have one
in my life I have one in my uh backpack
and they are wonderful really yeah for
luggage as we travel on the road it's a
great idea but like you should have one
in your car all right Neil Brennan and
he has one that they're designed to have
one it's embedded into the wallet so he
just kind of is always one just in his
wallet and it's designed to have an air
tag in it amazing I'm gonna get a whole
bunch yeah I mean Caesar Millan great
Caesar Milan the Dog Whisperer yes who
is now divorced from his ex-wife he
tried to put an air tag in it put a chip
in it yeah
right in real though people are putting
them on their dogs and their collar and
their children uh people who have family
where someone has Alzheimer's or a
dementia they have like they have
pendants and things that they can wear
that it's just chip and put a chip in
them yeah put a chip in them uh
brilliant police told simonini on
October 30th officers had found her car
but she does not know when she will get
it back in its condition I have no idea
if it's involved in something that could
be potent that could potentially
potentially put me or my child at risk
so this too at this point you contact
like one of those crazy shows like Pimp
My Rider West Coast Auto or whatever and
you take apart my car just they and
they're like you know this happened
Sam's Club is in conjunction with these
crazy guy with the mustache who's always
yelling at his kid you're talking about
American Chopper yeah you get that guy
that's not West Coast Auto but West
Coast Chopper talking about Randy on a
Thursday with his daughter if you get
this guy and like you soup this bad boy
up and like it's got like a flat screen
TV in the back
tub in the front a fish tank so this is
what they say the policies so that this
never happens again the training so that
the training the employees they're
knowledgeable and accountable so they
will start asking is this your key Simon
and he said yeah that's the new policy
is this yours
show me ID I don't it said it took two
and a half days for Sam's Club I gave
you that to get her a rental car that's
too long two and a half days well let's
be fair though with the low mileage that
she has she's not going off she's not
going anywhere she probably said
whatever
uh she is uh asking for more uh than a
car replacement she said she wants to be
reimbursed also for the stress and
inconvenience that her family went of
course she did uh what do you think I
mean I think she's entitled to damages
I'm not gonna lie of course this is wild
this I mean yeah Sam's Club you gotta
have insurance for this type of thing
and once it becomes a story that the
world is talking about it it was about
no public relations uh great uh get her
a new car and your everyone loves Sam if
she if she if you if she go all I want
is my exact same car back but it doesn't
be the same one I made it but you could
get a 2014 2014 Honda Civic now the
mileage is below and that's it I mean
like on Craigslist it's at least under
it's probably around eight grand yeah
yeah
so you would pay less to pay a lawyer
even if you bumped her car up and said
we got you the brand new no no we got
you the 2015. enjoy for all your
products
here's the 2000 I gave you a year on
your life gave you a year yeah
all right that's Story number one what
is going on there though what is the
chaos of a Sam's Club how hard is it of
a Sam's Club ballet like but how many
cars did they get in for tires we have
no idea it could be a nightmare working
there or the guy's just really frazzled
like the first car comes back and the
guy's waiting he's like I'm in the weeds
Dan you've got Story number two when we
come back Dan's gonna have a story but
first we're gonna tell you what we're up
to and we're gonna tell you how to
support Tom Papa with all the great
things that he has going on because dumb
people town with Tom Papa don't go
anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get to all the great things Tom is
doing we always constantly remind you go
to supersclass.com you can see where
we're performing where we'll be soon
coming to a town near year end of March
we're in Phoenix March 4th I don't know
if this goes on before after March or
March 4th we're at the Lawrence uh Event
Center in Lawrence Indiana which is
outside of Cincinnati in Louisville uh
and then at the end of the month we'll
be in Phoenix at uh stand up live what a
great Club stand up live is downtown big
Club want to fill that thing if we can
then at moon tower in April and then in
uh May we're in Minneapolis
superscars.com and then you can see all
the local shows that we're doing and we
may do our wonderful show tag it which I
would invite both of you guys to come
through I ever get air tags at it yeah
lots of [__] so no YouTube comic friends
of ours do their set of comedy and then
uh we are feverishly writing tags for
their jokes during your set and then we
come on stage and we pitches so much fun
it's super fun and people always come
out of it with material it's really
really fun
but we've been given many great ones
through the years so it feels like we
say let's take what happens in the back
hall and put it up on stage I love it so
that we might do it at the comedy tour
in the middle of April we're looking at
potentially April 12th what no hang on a
second wait no we both promoted you
being on the show
um breaking bread with uh Tom Papa and
and your wonderful Show on Netflix as a
joke yeah we're still doing it with
Fortune the great Fortune picture the
Netflix show yeah fantastic on us my new
book is ready for pre-order oh there we
go give us the title we're all in this
together so make some room that's great
and it's available wherever books are
sold and it comes out uh June but you're
gonna do it right now yeah gonna do a
book tour go run around which will be
probably super easy for you because
you're reading a chapter and then
telling stories it's not like you gotta
hit these jokes every couple of seconds
but it'll probably be the funniest best
book stops ever on my last book thing I
did a thing where like a couple
different authors at like a librarian
convention which by the way millions of
librarians very cool and uh the other
guys were not Comics so you're just
crushing so they're like just reading
verbatim and you're like their thing and
like and I'm reading it I'm like
skipping you know you're editing on the
fly yeah of course and just you could
just Crush right and they're just so
angry
and then there's that moment where all
the Librarians take down their hair and
they're gorgeous and you're like they're
all for me yeah
um all right so the book uh so again one
more time we're on this together so make
some room
uh Daniel couple before you do your
story yeah uh every week Irene too and I
have a show you can go to
danielvankirk.com for that that's on
Wednesday nights and then also I'm
constantly working new material at my my
home club which is uh the secret group
in Houston I'm there once a month for
would you rather comedy and all that
stuffs at danielvankirk.com and I'll be
at moon tower as well doing stand up in
a living wake in a dumb people Town
ready yep send it by Carlene McDermott
at chibi Carlene great family this is
such a dumb people Town story here's the
headline man who hasn't stopped farting
Sue's food stall yeah it's their food
stall yeah like I guess like like a food
truck Market where you walk up and order
something like like a food court like a
food tent like at a farmer's market I
guess there's parts of the farmer's
market at the Grove here that you would
consider it's a food stall
you serve them a sapuna a dad
is suing a food stall because he claims
he hasn't stopped farting since eating a
ham sandwich
how many years ago yo Daniel stop it how
many years ago Jason guess first there's
a statue of limitations three years
three years because you said years but
it can't be that many well
years ago Thomas five
he says I'm suing this goddamn food
stall because I had a ham sandwich there
and that's what's been causing me to
fart
for five years
[Laughter]
Tom knows what goes into a sandwich
full presidential term and a year so now
Tom I want you to put on your parenting
and family man and husband hat so all
the people in your house your two
daughters and your wife are like you
gotta stop farting and you're like it's
not myself right and that discussion
happens over and over again to the point
where you're like I have to do something
about it I have to blame someone yeah
that's exactly what happened they just
aged he aged and yes it has loose bowels
now and just keeps farting and the idea
that he's narrowed it down two honey one
entree item on one like I could see
people be like you know I've had gas
issues since like November of land maybe
my stomach is messing like I don't know
about three four years ago I just
started getting gas the fact that he's
still that ham sandwich on that day is
why she's leaving this is a fight yeah
it's a food Vendetta right Tyrone
parades bought the sandwich in December
2017 during a visit to Birmingham
Christmas Market
so this is like an outdoor open-air
Christmas Market this is supposed to be
celebrating the birth of our Lord do you
think he
he did not like get gifts for anybody
and so he played that he was sick due to
the ham sandwich and now he's had to
like ride out the Christmas that he
ruined right for five years we're gonna
take this to Legal yeah or it ruined the
this beautiful Christmas outing at the
thing with the family yeah he definitely
farted in a baby's face yeah and he was
like Dad what are you what are you doing
Life is Crying your children don't
believe in Santa anymore look at him
this ham sandwich we all had the I Am
sandwich from there you're the only one
who's playing
do you see the guy that made mine with
those dirty fingers yeah I didn't trust
him his lawyers told the high court uh
this is from The Daily Star uh in the
YouTube UK uh his lawyers told the high
court that he suffered stomach cramps
fever vomiting and diarrhea within hours
of eating it I'm I'm on board for that
you could have gotten some bad poisoning
yes go back and they'll be like we'll
give you your money back and that's the
way it claims to have been bedridden
with for five weeks with salmonella
bedridden bedridden salmonella that's
not it were there eggs yeah that's like
this is cooked meat I know ham and eggs
no but ham doesn't even have to be does
that have to be cooked it could be raw
yeah it can be cold I think you have to
cook it not to hear me raw I think you
have to cook it you gotta cook it yeah I
think it's cooked with the conserved
cold thank you but it's already been
it's already been smoking it's like
Revenge
Honey Baked sure this guy really felt
the lawyers added that parades I keep
wanting to say Padres or parades but
it's parades parades has had regular and
uncontrollable flatulence ever since
embarrassing him in public and waking
him up at night I just wanna yeah you're
older I woke myself up the other night
yeah he's not he's you can't be too sure
you're like who's in here you said that
and you know we're on the road all the
time you're usually alone yeah I was
with my wife and I was just like whomp
and I woke myself I was like and I kind
of giggled and then I realized it wasn't
alone
if it's early dating she's at brunch the
next time being like look people fart I
get it but he laughed about it himself
he doesn't even care about the air in
our bedroom I heard a glass in our
kitchen almost yet yeah I was like I
checked my phone to see if something
happened on the Richter Scale in
Northridge his lawyer this is parades
lawyer Tyrone's his lawyer uh Bob Parkin
I love it I love a goodbye Bob Parkin is
an improv team name yeah
I'm parking we got a space for you right
on his butt Bob Parkin told the court
that parade stomach continued to make
awkward and rumbling noises after the
illness subsided Parkin said the
claimant continues to suffer from
excessive excessive flatulence which
causes him a great deal of embarrassment
exactly the symptoms are primarily
fatigue and altered bowel function
associated with churning within his
abdomen and flatulence so many things to
treat this right yeah like honesty
[Laughter]
macrobiotics why don't you just be
honest you love farting probiotic feels
good no one's telling you it doesn't
feel good
eating a lot of cheese every day yeah I
told you
2017. the climate stomach continues to
make frequent churning noises to the
extent his sleep can become disrupted
you know about I would buy that his
stomach was haunted the extent of his
symptoms for a ham sandwich he's got a
belly ghost
the extent of his symptoms have been
life-changing which is why he is seeking
damages in the amount of how much money
how much money do you think he wants to
get from one million pounds okay I have
no idea what that would convert about
one point dollars about 1.6 1.5
uh 750 000 okay five hundred thousand
dollars he's seeking damages of
247 800 so specific wow do you think
that if I'm more specific I'm gonna get
it no he's got some bills in here that
he's like he's added up some bills
how much you spent in time and his
lawyer's probably like let's just call
it 250 and he's like no if I say
247.8 well no I'm serious I'm not making
the number I really want 240. so let's
yeah that's like a low like no low
ballers number like you like that's as
far as all goes that's all I'm letting
in I do my I was with my nine-year-old
daughter and uh and I was outside
walking hiking with her and I'm like I'm
gonna fart oddly but I'm gonna talk over
it loudly she knows that when I talk
loudly over things I'm either covering
up swearing on the radio or farting
she's like we're not listening to the
radio so I know what's happening
so that sun looks kind of bright over
there yeah you ever do the dad thing
where you obviously don't do it like
common around the house it's like okay
and every once in like five years just
let a really masterful one just in the
middle of the kitchen yeah man The Joy
from the build up of not doing it oh it
feels so good it has such impact what is
wrong
wrong on the offensive and I blame my
nine-year-old daughter gee what do you
why would you
there are people in here come on
near death and you're doing this the
lawyer also alleged that the stall in
question was closed and deep clean
following a public health England
investigation okay he knows other
customers who bought food at the market
reportedly fell ill grades uh his case
hinders on on whether or not the
flooring company boss I guess yes
I know it's like what he does whether or
not the flooring company boss was
suffering from salmonella Philip Davey
the Barrister of her Frankfurt Christmas
Market limited which served the ham
sandwich admitted admitted Council
environmental health officers found E
coli on a knife but no salmonella he
said that as parades has not claimed he
suffered from an E coli infection he
must prove the salmonella allegedly
allegations
he picked the wrong one I didn't want to
ask you guys we'll get out of here on
this how old
is Tyrone prades how old how old of a
man do you think how old is a good
Christmas ham sandwich has been farting
for five years and wants 247 points
eight hundred thousand dollars I'm gonna
put him at I'm gonna put him at 42. okay
so by the way I think that of the pound
is probably
1.478 so he probably just asked for 200
000 I don't know maybe that's for like
two two hundred thousand pounds yeah
that's what he asked for and then that's
what it is because the dollars I'm just
throwing it out there
oh that makes sense I don't know it'd be
like a one point 42 because his bowels
are starting to loosen up he's not a
young man no okay Jason I'm gonna say 57
57 years old and Randy's 38. he's like
why is this happening to me right now
yeah 57 maybe diarrhea but not
flatulations before we go to Randy and
his story number three I will end this
story by telling you that Tyrone parades
is
46 years old
Story number three I'll give you just a
little teaser we got it it takes place
near a Chuck E cheese okay near me
you gotta listen to find out
people town with Tom Papa don't go
anywhere
stick around
people
townies we love ferrity I love their
clothes so much they craft quality
clothes that feels as good as the day at
the beach and they are backed by their
guarantee of quality imma say this Jay
summer starts with Verity yes look good
stay cool be cool with effortless warm
weather styles with their t-shirts
shorts swimmer I got every single type
in the swim trunks yeah they're shorts
that also are swim trunks I wear those
they're so good you'll be ready for
whatever that started by our friends
Mike and Alex their twin brothers Jay we
got that twin brothers what did I say to
you yesterday without knowing the answer
do you remember you said to Jason about
Jason no I thought it was you to my left
no it was Jay you were like Jay that
shirt looks like it's unbelievable tell
me that's fair to you like you better it
is you bet it is you know it is so we
are in that terry cloth yeah and you had
on the knit beige that's right oh my God
my daughter felt the terry cloth shirt
that I was wearing she's like it's like
if a towel became a shirt I was like
yeah that was good I said three words to
you I go I'm getting that yes right well
their styles are so cool the colors are
good you know me I love a good pattern I
love all their love the good feather
stuff is Native American patterns they
just do really cool stuff that is super
comfortable all the legend sweater uh
flannels and the stuff that you'll have
for a long time through many seasons
I've had from them for like five just
keep adding to it Dan tell them how they
can do this all right guys Verity is
giving all dumb people Town listeners an
amazing deal townies you can get 20 off
your order all you have to do is head to
faritybrand.com DPT that's
f-a-h-e-r-t-y-b-r-a-n-d.com slash DPT
and use the code d p t two zero that's
dpt20 at checkout Dan you did say you
liked my Waffle pattern I did yes look
get the clothes use the code and then
when you show up at our shows show up in
the fairy clothes and be like I got this
stuff
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to uh the show I'm
gonna bring us home with one final story
do you ever think about air tagging your
audience just yeah to find out where
they are yeah at all times still with us
where are you guys laughing at the
check-in you ready for this yes
uh Jake Magnuson
Jake magnusson is a bunch of uh magnets
for Madison this is a Magnus for
Magnuson of sending in stories here is
the uh the headline woman fire shot oh
boy during fight outside Chuck E cheese
in Brandon oh Brandon oh this definitely
started in the truck so this started in
the Chuck E cheese build out so do you I
mean do you miss those days when you
take your kids to Chuck E cheese did you
ever go to a Chuck E cheeseburger of
course you did of course you did
[Laughter]
[Music]
you answered as though somebody asked
you about the war you were in you're
like yeah there is a little PTSD right
there was I mean because there was there
was joy in the early days of the Chuck E
cheese it was like it was fun what a
goof yeah
watch everybody go nuts and then one
time I had bad news about a pilot that I
had done it I found out that morning
that I we weren't making the show
and then had to go to a Chuck E cheese
birthday party hell I'd tell and just
sitting there in the stickiness
and it's like what have I done with my
life yes oh that is like the lowest yeah
it was like how how humble does God want
you to be yes yeah you know what I mean
I'm laying on the ground so that's where
that's where the pause came from because
you're like really like I've got a
Gandhi up this day I'm gonna take these
8 000 tickets and buy a noose oh what I
don't have enough for the news
so Chuck E Cheese's we've done it again
maybe this is one more uh this maybe
just one of the craziest situations ever
to befall a Chuck E cheese nearby or
whatnot Brandon Florida of course WFLA
the Hillsborough County Sheriff's Office
we've already been in here we've already
been in Hillsboro yeah uh Sheriff's
responded to an incident at a Chuck E
cheese in Brandon on Saturday according
to your release from the Sheriff's
Office deputies responded to multiple
calls reporting shots fired outside
Chuck E cheese at 1540 WS Brandon uh
West Brandon Boulevard at around what
time time so at least you have to deal
with gun play yeah you're like Pilots
down but and I feel terrible but at
least people aren't shooting at each
other right she is so depressed to even
lift a gun it all started from an
altercation that happened inside the
restaurant but at what time did they
report the shots what are the hours of a
Chuck E cheese there you go so I mean
it's a 10 a.m fight that's just carrying
over from a parent being drunk all night
or is this happening in the day what do
you think I I'm gonna put it at brunch
I'm gonna say this is a 1pm or 1pm
Daniel what do you think I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go I'll go late then I'm gonna
go uh around seven p.m three in the
afternoon okay that sounds potent that
is get your answers in townies because
this took place at five PM
I was close altercation inside the
restaurant a private security guard was
trying to get the crowd to take the
fight outside that's when you know
you're in a Chuck E cheese I can't stop
it's gonna happen I just need to move it
off of my watch I know he's an [__]
but talk about it in the park I mean
imagine security guard when you're a
rich town with a lot of pollution
you're gonna have a better shot at him
from outside right it's like there's no
obstacles this part the security guard
being like I this I can't do my job and
break this fight oh no no I know this
fight's gonna happen I got kids stuck in
two trying to get it if you're gonna do
the fight do it outside I'm not saying
don't do that yeah nobody's saying don't
do the fight you're not saying you have
to go home you just can't fight here
yeah yeah
so you're gonna love it out there
there's so much room okay so here's what
happened so he actually did try to do
something okay the guy was trying to get
the crowd to take the fight outside when
a woman pulled out a gun inside the
vestibule of a Chuck E cheese so the
guard tried to take the gun away from
her but she dropped it outside the
building the sheriff's office said
another woman picked up the gun and
fired it at least one shot into the air
I'm just trying to calm everyone down so
you're you tried to start the New York
Marathon why am I an [__] if you're
the person in a fight who sees a gun go
on a floor and then rushes to pick it up
and shoot it who are you is that Mike
Royce's old joke uh what the New York
Marathon starts with a gunshot early in
the morning and then people running
throughout New York City is like how's
that different than any other day in New
York City a
so then the position a third woman then
picked it up and placed it inside of a
light gray Chevrolet Traverse oh there's
a lot of people why are people this is
like this could be a children's book of
what happened to the gun at Chuck E
cheese right give him give a mouse a gun
do you have a drunk woman a gun she's
gonna take it to a Chevy Traverse all
three women were taken to custody and no
shooting victims were located so I think
they just shot it up in the air there's
prints all over this gun they did it to
confuse everyone if we all touch it none
of us can get arrested we all touch it
none of us touch it a man involved in
the allocation was also taken into
custody I'm glad that it's like three
women and some dude but I will say this
like women involved in like a gun
incident and no one gets shot so right
if you think that at least they're
aiming it up so I feel like this is a
crazy story right this next paragraph is
like I can't believe this happened in
the same story Chuck E cheese now offers
a gun
ammunition for eight thousand tickets
Dan I wish it was that logical okay
because what is about to happen again
this story it's so dumb people down the
sheriff's office said a white Audi
crashed into the front of a building
while the group was fighting
yeah this is how the purge starts
[Laughter]
crashing this is like the beginning of
the last of us and then I would argue
that it's just a regular Sunday of Chuck
E cheese 100 this is making my Chuck E
cheese experience much from the right
mean well the Michaels started on fire
two women and a child were taking the
hospital with non-life-threatening
injuries the male driver was also taking
the hospital but deputies they were
watching the fight not paying attention
where they were going and they drove me
during the whole melee at least one dad
left his family like this is my time
it's like a Bruce Springsteen song yeah
if I had a Chugga cheese I took a left
turn and just kept going I'm grateful
that nobody was seriously injured as a
result of this incident said that
Sheriff Chad
cronistered
thanks to the Swift considerable
response of our deputies we've been able
to quickly track down those responsible
and take them into custody while the
investigation continues into what led to
today's events Chuck E cheese provided
the following statement and I'm here to
read it by the way I think the statement
has to be made by the animatronic the
mouse
[Laughter]
we are aware of the incident that
occurred on Saturday someone here for a
hearing who's here to celebrate a
hearing which one of you has custody of
these kids your LoJack is going off sir
your ankle bracelet is beeping
Here Comes an Audi
crashing into the wall all right so
we're a vehicle crashed into our
storefront we want to assure our guests
that we take great measures to protect
the experience Children and Families
have in our venues they right now dude
you're checking hey that guy did try
that know who you are the the safety so
I treat going to Chuck E cheese like a
how I treat playing pickup basketball at
age 51 years you're gonna get injured no
if I leave without an injury I win it's
a win I don't care if the party I don't
care I don't care if I lose the
basketball game if I'm driving home in
the car with all the same functions I
had when I got when I showed up we did
something we did one we won the general
manager on site and our team acted
members acted quickly alerted local
authorities they kind of did secure
medical attention for those involved we
are thankful for the dedicated service
to the community and law enforcement we
were cooperating with the police during
their ongoing investigation and cannot
offer any additional details at those
times those additional details will cost
you 8 thousand tickets if I had written
my pilot about this incident
just three people
there's a show about Blockbuster we we
need a picture I think we absolutely
there was a place in St Louis called
ShowBiz Pizza
where a kid can be a kid when they have
the Showbiz band oh my god well there
you go that's a [__] great show Tom Papa
again people can pre-order your book
tell them the name one more time wrong
together so make some room that's God
that's a beautiful choice right just
make some room for the audience
pre-order right now pre-order that right
now and support him and then listen to
And subscribe to uh breaking bread with
Tom Papa yes beautiful podcast listen to
a serious radio uh show on Netflix is a
joke the Netflix uh Channel with Fortune
name of that show is this is not what a
joke what a joke fantastic we've done it
and love it and we'll be back on
um that was so great being here I love
it and I love you Tom Papa no [__] we
gotta get back to work Jesus
choo choo
stick around
people town
[Music]